another thing from biden speaking of
very politically unpopular here's biden
yesterday addressing teachers and i want
you to to listen to what he says here
and speaking of midterms one thing i'll
say is that i i really hope
that joe biden takes this message and
the democrats they take this messaging
and take it right into the midterms
please do i beg you listen to this
have the best educated
public in the world
have our students
gain confidence enough to know what they
can do
to reach in
we have an obligation
we have a location to help them
teach
and reach their potential
you've heard me say it many times
about our children but it's true they're
all our children
and the the reason you're the teachers
of the year is because you recognize
that
they're not somebody else's children
they're like yours when they're in the
classroom
represent a profession
that helps them gain the confidence
the confidence they believe they can do
anything
they're not somebody else's children
they're yours when they're in the
classroom
please
joe that take that that that that's a
winner yeah please take that all the way
to the midterms
they're not and what does it mean by
somebody else's it means the parents
they're not somebody else's
the parents
no they're your children because they're
in the classroom
um and that is that's this is not a gaff
you didn't misspeak here that's exactly
what democrats think
that is precisely the leftist position
is that when the kids are in the
classroom they're in the government
classrooms government building
government school system and that means
that they belong to the government that
is their position they're not usually
quite that explicit about it but they
get pretty close
and this is a moment when joe biden was
very explicit about it that's how they
see it
you send your children to us and they
our
they are ours
and not only when they're in the
classroom by the way but even when they
leave
they're still hours
that's how they see it
and it's it's good it's it's a very good
to know now they're they're wrong about
that of course
you are entrusted if you're a teacher in
a public school classroom
um you know depending on what grade
level you might
you might have the kids entrusted to you
for 45 minutes at a time you have a
different group of kids 45 minutes and
they are entrusted to you for a specific
purpose
not as an adoptive parent it's not as
foster care
not even as daycare at least that's not
what what schools are supposed to be
even though even though they're treated
that way
you are simply entrusted to impart
certain information to the kids on a
certain subject that's all you're
supposed to be doing that's the only
that's your whole job
and not not to say that it's that it's a
small or minor thing it's quite a noble
job to do an important one
if you actually do the job you're
supposed to do and take it seriously
and don't try to do more than that job
by taking these children under your wing
and turning them into your own kind of
de facto children because they're not
but it isn't it is
crucial for us to understand that um
this is how the government education
system sees it
and when you send your kids to the
school even though they are still your
kids you are sending them into a system
that believes
that they have ownership
of the parental
rights that actually belong to you
all right speaking of which
from the daily wire rhode island
democrats are pushing legislation that
would teach children about
pleasure-based sexual relations
pleasure-based sexual relations
with the support of left-wing groups the
legislation senate bill 2285 would amend
current law so that culturally
appropriate courses in quote family life
or sex education are taught to children
beginning in sixth grade when students
are about 11 or 12 years old
quote
teachings would recognize pleasure-based
sexual relations
different sexual orientations and be
inclusive of same-sex relationships the
act would also provide that instruction
include gender gender expression gender
identity and the harm of negative gender
stereotypes
this is what they want to do in uh
rhode island rhode island state senator
tierra mack a democrat representing
providence one of the primary sponsors
of the bill has cited her southern
abstinence-only sex education as a
reason for pushing
sb2285 she said there was no
conversation about what it meant to be
gay or what a healthy relationship
looked like sex education is about
learning about gender and gender roles
about what it's like to grow up in a
single parent family it's about all the
things i wish i had gotten it's about
knowing i wasn't alone
that's what she says and in fact here
mac i think we have a uh video of her
she's interviewing talking a little bit
about
about this pleasure-based sex ed and uh
here's what she has to say about that
an opportunity came up to teach sex ed
um through a program at the university
called sexual health advocacy through
peer educators to teach sex ed um to
local high school students and i did
that my sophomore year um after um
applying my freshman year i'm like well
if i didn't know this like there are
people out there like me who literally
have no idea how to talk about their
body how to access agency and how to
actually um practice autonomy in
whatever way they want to do it and for
me that was unlocking conversations
about my body my sexuality and my
identity in a safe and um culturally
sensitive and respectful environment and
also sharing that with 15 year olds who
at the time are yearning to have that
conversation and i taught that said all
throughout the rest of my
college career and then i went to go on
to teach high school math and i still
was teaching sex education and at the
time at the same time still working on
issues surrounding reproductive health
rights and access from local abortion
funding work and to now being on the
board and abortion fund and being an
employee of planned parenthood southern
new england it's been the core of my
work
yeah so that's what she wants this is
what you think sex ed should be it
should be about as she said in the in
the article it's about knowing i'm not
alone it's about it's about discovering
your body or whatever else she's talking
about um
no sex ed is is
not supposed to be any of that in fact
there should you know we're at a point
now where you just have to get sex out
of the schools completely
for for every grade level
you know k-12 no sex out of any kind get
it all out this is not um you know no no
i'm not saying let's have
abstinence-only education instead of
this instead of the so-called
comprehensive sex education no i don't
want that either i don't i don't i don't
need
if i set my kids to public school which
i don't but if i did
i wouldn't need teachers
talking to my kids about how to abstain
from sex and the advantages of that
that's not a conversation that i'm going
to trust to strangers
okay i can have that conversation i
don't need you to do it i don't trust
you to do it
but of course we're way beyond
abstinence education
and they want this which is on the other
the total other end of the spectrum my
point is
just take the whole spectrum and throw
it out
um
we just cannot trust these perverts
to
have conversations with kids about sex
at all
okay so
there should be no
subject no course called sex ed
you want to talk about reproduction
you talk about that in biology
you want to talk about anatomy
talk about that that's also a science
discussion so you can cover those
but anything beyond that
even if in theory
you know there could be a version of a
sex ed class that's appropriate in
theory which i haven't even heard what
that version would be
even if you could in theory figure out
such a curriculum you cannot trust the
teachers to do it
you just can't as as we see here because
they have taken this
keep keep something else in mind here
that for them
sex
and their sex life and their sexual
orientation and they're generating any
like that's
that's their whole existence
that's everything that's all they care
about so so everything gets wrapped up
in that that's also their religion
and that's why she says oh sex is about
it's about knowing sex ed's about
knowing yourself and knowing you're not
alone and what
what does knowing you're not alone have
to do with sex ed what are you talking
about
well it's because her whole identity and
life and everything is wrapped up in sex
[Music]
and that's yet another reason why you
can't trust these people to talk to kids
about sex listen hit that subscribe
button right now do it right now i thank
you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated